olivier raymond qui est médecin
généraliste à londres bonjour à vous
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur
arte france dites nous quelle est la
situation aujourd'hui au royaume uni
c'est très difficile de nous entend
alors est-ce que vous m'entendez la
medefi cinq ans quelle est la situation
aujourd'hui royaume-uni d'accord donc à
l'ombre de cas en ce moment beaucoup de
décès on s'est pris un peu plus tard que
la france pour faire le look down et
maintenant je pense qu'on paie un petit
peu le prix les médecins privés comme
loi nous avons reçu aucun masque
aucun équipement c'est très compliqué et
je pense que dans le système public
rennais chess c'est un petit peu mieux
mais pareillement qu'en france je pense
ils n'ont pas tout ce qu'il faut et
c'est assez compliqué de voir les
patients autrement que par watt ça sans
avoir de protection quel regard vous
masse tout ce qu'il faut quel regard
vous portez sur la façon dont elle les
pouvoirs publics ont géré cette crise au
royaume uni au départ comme vous le
savez boris johnson un peu joué
cavalièrement en disant que ce n'était
pas très grave et que l'angleterre étant
unis le peut-être s'en sortir et un
petit peu mieux sans faire de leur
langue
malheureusement à son à sa mauvaise
conscience et il a payé un petit peu le
prix et même beaucoup et maintenant le
pays est un petit peu dans la situation
où l'espagne a quelques semaines je
parlais des chiffres tout à l'heure on
observe un léger mieux
comment vous interprétez vous les
derniers chiffres je souhaite de tout
coeur que ce soit quelque chose de
positif et de et que ça va durer comme
ça mais je n'en suis pas très sûr parce
qu'il ya quand même lu beaucoup de
personnes qui sont sorties dans les
parcs il faisait très beau donc liste
publiée une recrudescence le temps que
l'incubation se fasse et que les
symptômes apparaissent
mais j'espère et comme dans les autres
pays qu'on va commencer à voir les
chiffres diminué grâce au look down
maintenant j'adorais être sûrs et être
nous dit là mais malheureusement je ne
sais pas vraiment ce qu'il en est et la
situation dans les maisons de retraite
très mauvaise très mauvaise ça a été tu
lé pendant pas mal de temps et là
seulement cette semaine on commence à
avoir des chiffres qui apparaissent et
qui ne sont pas très réjouissant c'était
plus que probable vu la situation des
personnes qui sont là des des tares
médical ou physique et qu'ils qui l'on
danse était pratiquement sûr qu'ils
allaient avoir une entre guillemets
hécatombe dans les maisons de retraite
est-ce qu'on a des chiffres ce que vous
vous avez eu des échos des chiffres qui
vous ont été remontés pas vraiment c'est
un petit peu le secret à la télé tous
les soirs lors du point quotidien donne
certains chiffres mais je ne sais pas si
c'est vraiment la vérité moi je connais
quelques patients qui sont en état d'
anglais en ont maison et ya pas mal de
cas quand même je ne sais pas s'il ya
les décès c'est très difficile à savoir
mais les cas positifs où il ya quand
même pas mal parce qu'il faut quand même
expliqué dr là bas au royaume uni c'est
vrai qu'on peut pas vraiment parler des
paliers a certainement d'aider des
centres publics pour accueillir les
personnes âgées mais beaucoup de maisons
de retraite privées
tout à fait si vous pouvez
avoir l'argent nécessaire pour aller
dans des maisons privées
c'est ce qui est le plus demandé c'est
ce qui est le plus sur le territoire
pour les autres c'est très compliqué ici
a malheureusement aussi bien je pense
qu'en france ça fait 25 ans que je suis
en angleterre alors j'ai un petit peu
oublié comment ça se passe en france
mais c'est vrai qu'ici c'est très
difficile très défini on parlait tout à
l'heure servi beaucoup moins - étayé
moins bien construite en france on
parlait tout à l'heure pour terminer de
boris johnson qui a été atteint par le
colis de 19 ans il s'en est sorti après
avoir été hospitalisé on disait on a eu
l'impression qu'ils n'avaient pas pris
la mesure de la gravité de cette
pandémie aujourd'hui est ce qui change
le curseur aujourd'hui pas oui oui je
pense que là à ses dépens il a compris
et il change les curseurs on ne l'a plus
vu à la télé depuis quelques temps a pas
quand il est sorti de l'hôpital pour
remercier les médecins et les
infirmières qui s'était occupé de lui
mais sinon c'est son ministre des
finances ou ministre de l'intérieur qui
parle et on voit que quand même
maintenant ils veulent que l'on reste
encore confiné pendant un certain temps
et même peut-être les personnes âgées
jusqu'à noël
merci beaucoup olivier raymond d'avoir
été en direct avec nous sur rt france
rappelle que vous êtes médecin
généraliste à londres bon courage à vous
également